المصائب لا تاتي فرادى مثل ينطبق على
طائره تويتر الذي استحود عليه اغنى رجل في
العالم مصاعبه ايلون ماسك تستمر وتتفاقم
مجموعه امنيكم ذات الصيت الواسع في عالم
الدعايه والتسويق والتي تقدم الخدمه لاكثر
من 5000 عميل في سبعين دوله توصي عملائها
بوقف انفاقهم مؤقتا على الاعلانات في
التويتر على المدى القصير وقف الى حين
انقشاع الغيوم الملبده عن سماء الشركه
تقول المجموعه الخطوه تؤكد شكوكا متزايده
بين الوكالات والعلامات التجاريه حول
مستقبل موقع تويتر
مقابل 44 مليار دولار خاصه وان خمسه 10
شركه سبق وان علقت مؤقتا اعلاناتها في
المنصه ماسك انحاء بلائمه على مجموعات
حقوق المدنيه في انخفاض الايرادات بشكل
كبير مع ضغطها على فينا لمقطعه الخدمه الى
ان يوضح كيف سيتحكم في المعلومات المضلله
وخطاب الكراهيه على تويتر فبعد ان ابعد
الكثير من الموظفين وقرر فرض رسوم على
الحسابات الموثقه ماسك اعلن ان المنصه
مهدده بالافلاس في وقت يواصل فيه اطلاق
النار في كل اتجاه بلال الوجداني العربيه